[Music]
crazy here in Los Angeles today the
president is in town President Obama is
here you see we're ruining the traffic
for all of us oh wow he just lost a lot
of votes
ya know President Obama is in town
tonight for a fundraiser at George
Clooney's house where dinner yet this is
$40,000 a plate
yeah when Mitt Romney heard this he said
that's ridiculous you can't get a decent
meal for 40 fast not with wine not in
Studio City no no yes say this is true
this is their saying yesterday President
Obama said he he came out in favor of
gay marriage because his position has
evolved then today he flew to George
Clooney's house yes so apparently things
were evolving a lot faster than we
expected that's the quick I think it's
romantic I do too
you've always been a softy about these
well yeah yeah yesterday President Obama
announced he's changed his mind that he
now supports gay marriage yeah that's
right
the the White House admitted this is
interesting that Vice President Joe
Biden's endorsement of gay marriage
forced President Obama to come out in
favor of it yeah so in a related story
millions of young Americans are now
trying to get Biden hooked on pot yeah
[Applause]
do you think he's chatty now I know Mitt
Romney apologized today after it came
out that he bullied fellow students back
in high school now apparently he held a
kid down and said over and over again
your dad only has one house no this is
true Mitt Romney has issued Mitt
Romney's issued an apology for some of
his high school pranks that I guess went
a little too far yeah probably the
meanest prank was the time Romney bought
his high school and fired everyone in it
I tried to do that for $9 yeah I think
the TSA has gone too far and I'll tell
you why this week a baby a baby was
pulled off a plane by the TSA for being
a potential terrorist
baby yeah yeah the action was slammed by
parents groups and applauded by anyone
who's ever flown with a baby
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been hit yeah the the best-selling
S&M novel Fifty Shades of Grey has been
banned from many libraries in Florida
isn't that shocking
they have libraries in Florida a town in
New Jersey is now finding people who are
walking and texting yeah of course here
in Los Angeles we have our own way of
handling people who walk while texting
we run them over
[Applause]
[Music]
I actually saw a lady in - this in my
neighborhood this morning walking and
doing word search while she was crossing
the street like from a book while
crossing this wall crossing the street
and I thought how old-school of her to
get hit by a car doing word search word
Saoirse yeah that's sad according to a
recent study that just came out redheads
have more sex than other people
[Applause]
apparently the study was conducted when
I was out of the country
I drank the tear and it made me strong